Nah nah nah nah nah we're not going out like
that we not we not going out like this I
said I said we not going out like that today
man it's not the works got to get done no
we're going to face only mode
I'm hot
So I guess I finally turned up that AC on
their ass I had took the AC but now I've got
comfortable in the house babe
Hey I look like let me explain myself first
let's start with explaining myself but I was
That time when I've been up since 2:00 a.m.
man shit okay okay
Yeah I've been up since 2:00 a.m. and
I needed a break God damn it now now
I don't think I got shit done
They got caught up in political bullshit
And and yellow tape and and had to wait on
eight approvals
Between each otherAnd I ain't making no
better because I just kept adding.
More things that they had to get done
Before they would get my approval I still
have never given them my approval to get to
level two I was waiting to see I don't even
really know what I was waiting to see I
wanted to see them break out of these
acknowledgment loops
I am proud to say
My boy Blaze came to my stream yeah my boy
came to my streaming this thing you can't
take that back buddy yeah I already been
here and you didn't call me sleep now we
done slept together and they're crazy
I got to go to the restroom I'll be right
back
Think that fits the mood for what I'm
looking atAll right.
Now let's see if I could delete those but I
don't really want I don't really want y'all
seeing me sleep on stream but I ain't going
to lie to you I do not like that shit I do
not like that shit we got a we got to get
that shit going to meet you today yes we
going to start with that
And while we're at it let's go ahead and
start working on that switch box strategy
session and play the game with the kids
that's literally it's 3:00 all I got to do
is have a strategy session play the game
with the kids and
Make this twitch bite so let's let's connect
the switchbot to my switch chat and let's
see how we can do that
First thing we're going to have to do is for
this one particular I don't need multi-agent
orchestration I can just
Get it inBut I would like to go through each
agent.
And just kind of look at what they've
doneToday. Like this is what I did.
Oh you can't see it cuz I cut off the
thingRight I got to cut off this screen.
Anyway cuz I'm about to roll up so what's
going ahead andIt was nice to see me.
But now you don't you must cut you off and
get you back up here
I love it that's what I want to see fucking
work getting done bye
All right now
Where is Carmen Aria and RyanNo they're
definitely not in the room.
Okay how you don't know where everybody else
in the house is
Nobody's in the kitchen nobody's in the
house right now Ariel right now when I just
walked through the house I didn't see nobody
If they're not in until room they're not
here
Did you find themOkay you don't got to look
for him I'm just.
Like how did you get left out
Where were youWhere y'all go. Huh.
Outside whereNo cuz I was outside in the
front.
You know he was outside the phone no because
I just was out there in the front calling
for youSo.
If you was out in the front how you didn't
hear me calling for you
Yeah that shit sounds suspect it's what Then
you outside your nose.
HuhInteresting and you telling me you was in
front of the house.
But you didn't hear me calling youYeah I
don't. Yeah I don't believe you was out
there in front of the house.
Anyway where is Carmen that kitchen bad that
living room bad when we going to get to it
we going to wait till Grandma get here to
clean it and then I got to go out
You're not working
Show costumes
Stop running in my house little boy
And I know you're hurtingAnd I know you
heard me.
Then you say something
Crazy happy
Yes
Happy I finish we played a railroad game
It was awesome
Food
The raccoon window
And the sharks
?
Everything you want Snapchat for youI'm
leaving.
And she's RadioactiveIt's Real active.
Because he's already cool
ShoesThat's my mom said that we have a
shirt.
Puppet question mark
Do you like that oneNo.
I want Spider-Man
Is that pop
Japanese
Blood song238.
?
Get the girl had to get up to that show me
About meIt doesn't make me.
You're awesome please
And talk to me anywaysSo I'm just throwing
money.
I'm going down
I sleep sounds like that
It's just likeThat Sophia.
Like everyone
I like
In the second
It's still on the very one
Is only one
So many times
We just waited to the shop
How do you get so many money
Then you have Infinity dollars
I found you
Do we have
Two kids
And I didn't bring my phone when I
wantBecause if you're still unlocked up
there so.
Is everybody elseIs there.
Give me
Hey Google
How's
Play Roblox
Aria
Nevermind
Speed company
You
Not sure
Teresa
Playboy
Stop
Yeah
Right
Now
Give me me give me Carmen mean
This is the Christmas tree
I said don't make a raise for Christmas tree
I know what she said
Yes
If I
I'll help you I help you
Yes
That little notice just because you were
like okay Uncle bitchThat's how I could be
every time.
Loud
I need help
MariahGet home.
MayaNever came back with the other thing.
Did youDid you. Write.
Here I was doing this forever but I'm doing
this by myself
You don't need to work tomorrow we just need
to start off so we can open the Trulia
You got to tear this and we can open it
Okay
Christmas tree
Call me
And the only reason it's so bad is because
I've been asking since the beginning of time
and you ain't been giving a fuck
If the plates in there I will take the plate
up it'll be easier to do that in the sink
I will let that bitch just sit there in the
same soaking while I get the rest cuz it's
one of the only pieces that can sew
My foot
What we looking like over here who's still
working agent 6 still working are you
possible or are you still going you're
probably pause you're probably pause
And agent 6th is also
Oh no we still was rocking
Although now I got to rotate my keyBro.
Get that off the screen
BroI'm streaming.
The dumbass agent just expose my damn get up
token
Tickets
Because I can do what I mean still broke I'm
sorry I was going to be working till I can
figure out how to stay right
NowI figure it out.
Hey I ain't going to hold you thoughWhen you
went out there and y'all check that garage.
I ain't saying you got to get it now but I'm
sayingIf it raining.
You on your ass
I swear to God I ain't got enough green the
last through the night
Actually I might since I'll beSmoking by
myself.
Hell no I still ain't going to make itYou
laughing to me.
I said I ain't going to make I thought I was
like I said I ain't got to know we the last
through the night and then I was like oh
maybe I might cuz I'm be smoking by myself
And I was like never mind it's still ain't
enoughThen I thought you was laughing at me.
Let me borrow like $20Let me borrow $20.
You know I have to shoot my shotIf you mop
my flow I'll give you $3.
If you mind my bathroom floor I'll give you
three never mind I think I already mopped it
Yeah what you clean my would you clean my
mirror
For $3 I cuz I know I didn't do the mirror
that's the only thing I didn't do
The $3 is behind my behind my computer
It's the three dollars on the floor behind
my computer
Before you do it check to make sure it's
three dollars so I'm not lying
Allama says after you clean this microwave
this timeIf you see something.
Bro it's cuz it's enough it's enough bro
like at this point I'm not going back in
there and cleaning it no more
I don't even microwave food enough for that
all I eat is sandwiches
Hey what happened to the lights around my
window
To the lights around my windowAre you we
talked about this.
Call me
What happened to the lights around my window
Why can't put it all around the
weatherBecause I don't want that.
To be fair I both don't get nothing
NoI wanted it on my window.
And where we setting up the tree atAnd where
we setting up the tree at.
In front of meWe'll have to do it in the
corner behind me.
What
We would doThey call it a.
I forgot they call
You
Do you want it to be tacky around my in my
area
But can I do I reserve the right to see it
first
Time I don't like it
Accident on the couch
But me fan yeah let's try it let's see it
it's my way of saying okay I'm at least
giving it a shotCuz I could have just been
like.
Why don't get the white ones
Understand
I think I just want to say in advance
bullshitIt bush.
And I can tell they don't love me
Where is your site at where you at on your
site and what's today's Tuesday
Is a short day
How would I do it I do text and put it in a
squirt please
Delight in the Square inside the windows
You will have to get texts and put it like
in here nobody took this up I like to walk
right quick period
Is this big ass phone they broke my skin
That's the big that's the big pieceNo that
doesn't come out that's what I'm saying.
Instead
Money
Specially I can understand he did nothing in
his mom's broke so I understand his
reactions free time
There was no reasonYou got off on the top of
no reason.
Then then then we could also be like why the
fuck you put it on the side of the bed why
not put it on the dresser that's right next
to the bed on your side of the fucking dick
we can put we can try to point fingers but
I'm just picking and choosing my battles I
don't feel like fucking arguing cuz I
couldn't make an argument about that I told
him to stop putting it on the bed I said you
need to stop putting it something to end up
happening and what you doing
We can play fingers but the real thing that
goes towards this one
Because why she get off on the bed and the
worst part is it's like
You
??
I'm almost on that too I'm almost home
quitting smoking
And bare minimum from the motherfucking
dispenser like I've clocked it cannot be as
strong as normal week cuz I'm just going
through this week
Fucking buzzed I had some we had to mix it
with the dispensary
Lyrics
I hope you have a bud
Yeah so you say that the decision and the
more and more we keep smoking
And more and she fucking smoking it and
buying all of these hats and ounces and
shitAre tolerance.
That's interesting now I need another sample
size
Now I need another sample size
I don't want it to smell like his gas I
wanted to be gay right
You want to play visit that game now
DoneYou got something.
Right nowHey hey.
Cuz I got a whole stream going my boy it's
not the cash up
It's a FrostyNot supposed to be in here at
9:30 this morning.
Let me get that oneSomebody get that one.
Give me information
Mommy what
What I'm saying that cuz I want Whataburger
Ies
Yeah I'm getting taco Tuesday taco Tuesday
No I'm not I'm not no no no no noI said I'm
giving me a taco.
Everything
Silver you can make it feel good just wanted
to go out cuz Grandma here
Bring Me Some Water Burger
Are you thinking Whataburger no then you not
going
To hurt
You
I'm going to get back when you get this
right here ain't no tacos tomorrow though
Used to be Taco Bell
Without streaks in the window
Ain't fair if it's not a full clean window I
can get somebody else to clean the good
S
Whiskey
Not like
Yes sir I feel like you playing me on my
money
To do thatNo I still have to see if it's
clear or dirty.
Girl
All right that's clearlyNot funny.
I wanted to do that again
What's up
Decided nothing wrong now literally 10
minutes
Ago
Let me try to 75 hours for you but you know
they got me good
Please thank youCuz y'all.